your parents you have powerful parents
well how you don't know my [ __ ]
parents brother got hit by a keyboard
yeah my dad was violent
he was very violent and alcoholic he was
a rageaholic and he um he was just kind
of like a bad dad I think you know he's
sick now and I love him now but um
growing up I just remember like in the
back of our house was like a trail and
in the trail you could like go and
there's a cliff and I used to walk to
this cliff and sit there and just look
up at the stars and go can you please
kill him God never did you know about
your mother my mother was talking about
this now I want to I'm not afraid of
anything
my mother is um also very I drove her to
violence yeah I drove her to violent I
can believe that
why do you you're just your mom hit you
and you were just fighting it by saying
you were a little [ __ ]
oh well no I think my mom Jenna
generally isn't that violent but she
couldn't that was the last tool in the
toolbox
she tried every single bed yeah the way
she explains it to me is that he didn't
know how to receive any form of love or
affection or attention it's like
everything that she tried sports even
just lobbies hyperventilate it was
usually a little Tasmanian devil
basically right and you responded to
violence yeah I mean no I didn't respond
I responded negatively to it but um that
was at the end her last thing you know
was they would punch me in the face
Wow and he couplings yeah Steve Tube
Steve though my brother Steve growing up
was the one that was like the one he got
straight A's he was the choke rested
well not in his 20s he fell off but
younger he was like a Christian with the
church you know was on the reston team
got straight A's it's only later in life
where he became me
he he grew up under the same conditions
that you did what I love I love what
you're doing right now do you know what
you just did you know what to tell you
what you just did her you pull the Tom
Segura this now did I yeah he's got a
patent no no what he does was he he when
he was on our podcast and I want you to
I want you to do what I'm doing I want
to be doing it I'm not taking it away
from here right yeah we're talking about
power balance right now yeah but the
thing is is that what he did was he
became the host and you switched it a
little bit and I like what you're doing
no I like what you're doing the thread
and but that's your the thing is is that
I want you to have your power too
all right was that scene with the gnarly
black dude and Arnold strike hands from
predator well Arnold or defroster [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah there was yeah I don't
remember that that was us right now no
wasn't right but what was the question
about my mom what's then your brother
three years so you guys grew up under
the same conditions well I mean you know
here's the thing it's is that there's
you know immigrants come here and they
go you know the rules are just get
straight it listen yeah and get straight
A's yeah especially Koreans my family
and you'll be fine I didn't do either
one of those things you know I did drugs
at an early age
well I think the molestation when I
lived in Minnesota when I was nine or
whatever got me all like twisted up and
then when we came to San Diego at 12 or
11 I I found marijuana and skater or
isn't Filipinos that you know not really
them up you know really you know you
know I you know I
mean that as a joke what what what it is
is that you have to imagine I lived in
Minnesota where all I saw was white
people Minnesota is a rough I mean
that's a weird place to grow up kind of
yes yeah especially in the 70s yeah in a
net Dinah in a Minnesota it was like it
was you know but then I came to San
Diego and um on the other side lived I
grew up in Poway but on the other
that's town next to us was Penasquitos
Penasquitos is High School Mount Carmel
was sixty percent Filipino in fact my
senior year my senior year photo is in
the Mount Carmel yearbook do you know
why why is that because when they used
the same photographer and the foot I was
in the Poway high school pile and they
couldn't believe it
so they put it on to the mail pile and I
was in the Mount Carmel but here but my
find it Wow yeah somebody find it I
never went to Mount Carmel so it made me
do believe it actually and could I
assume because in my head I was like
place ooh you could have come up big
[Laughter]
we're your parents able to appreciate
that you were became so successful that
you kind of you turned it around right
because you took up very unlikely path I
like to speak a you feel uncomfortable
no tell me I'm automatically give it
away where are your parents I would
appreciate your success my parents um
well yeah they're sending you know when
you're you know your parents they grew
up in a different country
there's no stand-up comedy there on you
know I think my friend Danny chose out
there right now trying to start up a
movement but that's it's 2018 and they
don't have it yeah so imagine you know
my parents grew up in the Korean War as
kids and they went to school there and
my dad was a street hustler like he was
in the military became but as a kid he
used to like
Eve and Hughes didn't get a lot of I had
a rough yet a rough one yeah right
and then when he needed meat in Korea
they met here and my dad stalked my mom
pretty much damn what do you like flat
yeah he had her doors she had a move out
of LA and moved to Wisconsin and my dad
follow her she didn't know him at the
time he she did meet him and Nome and
she didn't like him Wow right so
persistent he's very persistent stalked
his way into a marriage yeah
and then when he showed up in Wisconsin
with a steak Hey
it was probably gonna cut nice cut nice
like a cowboy Texas cut right right
Yvonne and she was like in I guess in
Korea that's a big deal those are
diamonds you've had an interesting Road
yeah and then she was like I don't think
they hit the violence she saw you know
it you guys they play that game you know
I'm gonna beat this lady when I'm
married
[Music]
she deceived he deceived her and then
they had us and he'd started drinking
heavily and then um he would get on
these like alcoholic rage episodes and
um you know my brother and I grew up but
you know what here's the thing Mike also
my parents my dad was fairly wealthy he
had a bunch of like clothing stores we
grew up with um summer camp and when I
turned 16 I got a car you know me so
there was a lot of things that I did get
that was cool you know do you have good
parents my parents are pretty normal
yeah I would say normal give siblings I
have two siblings are you the oldest I'm
the baby
I was coddled I definitely had the best
of the three but I want to say I'm
really impressed by your I just want to
say I think you're survivor as well good
you know yellow what was your upbringing
like my parents my dad is very like
old-school so it's kind of hard you can
connect the dots on old school old
school mean he's Hasidic Jew no no yeah
like you mean like old school way of
raising kids a belt the good old way a
belt not it wasn't it was never like
aggressive towards me physically yeah
but it was always scary like I think if
you push him and make older yeah but you
played by the rules yeah you did Oh cuz
I was scared I'm still scared of him
yeah you know when she came here yeah
she almost didn't come he almost talked
her out of it really but she that's
probably the closest yelled to her not
her teacher he did hit your siblings
yeah it happened a couple times
really yes was he just nod was he
disapproving of you or disapproving of
moving everything yeah and how old were
you at that point what do you want did
do does he like uh no your dad
you know in as much as you can like
someone who's really so if you go to
Israel and you see her dad he smiles he
does smile would you hug like a lot yeah
okay we've been better damn yeah they're
like arguments there's interesting thing
yeah he doesn't speak English and I
don't speak Hebrew which is also a
reason that he's mad at him for not
learning Hebrew oh he's the kind of guy
who's mad at everybody yeah or something
his the family's been like it's so good
that you don't know Hebrew trust me you
don't want to know what's coming out oh
wow yeah but like the funny thing is
that when I came to live with me for a
year in America and went her beasts her
travel visa expired I didn't have any
other option was either moved to Israel
or breakup right yeah and because
there's this whole weird thing about if
you're Jewish you can just hightail to
Israel they give you citizenship ah so I
did that but the weird part was that I
went and lived with her parents whoa
whoa Joe was very extreme for how long
and we were months yeah we were we'd
they were like but no he would he didn't
let us even sleep in the same room
that's also cool we lived together for a
year I lived together for a year to be
together and he made me sleep in a
different room how did you guys hook up
we found a way they found some quiet but
were they quiet hours yeah
the same way dry humping is exciting
yeah yeah you just go back to the basics
the beginning that goes restraint it
makes things a lot more interesting yeah
you know well the thing is if I get
caught I'm [ __ ] I I'm gonna kill you
he's missing a finger he's old school
oh yeah coos ah yo figure that's good
did he do it through like some sort of
combat or always born without it just
from working with like heavy machinery
yeah yeah that's the way
[Music]